the red sox take on the nats tonight
that's chris mazza he gets a second
chance last time against the yankees
didn't go so well but you got to get a
starting pitcher to get deeper into a
game give the offense a chance to go
trey turner set to lead off
and turner
with a high fly ball to deep right
back back and pilar cannot get there and
it's going to bounce over the wall for a
fenway double the other way for trey
turner immediate rbi opportunity for
juan soto
backdoor breaking ball and that's
hammered out to center
turner will easily head for third on a
good swing by juan soto for the first
out productive out move the runner
kendrick draws a walk to put runners on
first and third for the cleanup man as
jubal cabrera mazza trying to escape and
he struck him out so in steps out of
meeting the right fielder
he's got it mazza will flip it on and he
gets out of that jam there's the arsenal
for anybody sanchez it's up to iron ball
to locate and maybe keep his pitch count
down first man up will be the left field
of verdugo
fastball that one driven into left field
and down for a base hit 90 mile an hour
swifty and verdugo equal to the task
well brings up the scuffling jd martinez
he'll hammer that one that's well hit
all the way back to the wall and that
one's going to catch the green
gradual
on his way to third and he'll stop there
on the double by martinez and that's a
little more like it so sox trying to
jump out in front second and third one
down for bogarts santa one for three
last night jumps on that that's well
struck that's heading for the 379 mark
and that ball is out of here
xander bogarts with a three-run homer
here in the first inning off sanchez
he got something high and he hit it
higher
boy he got a pitch to hit and he did not
miss it he crushed this high fastball
had nothing on it and he left the
ballpark and the sox jump out in front
kevin ballard to lead things off goes
after the first pitch and drives it deep
to dead center robles leaping and he
can't get it it's on the warning track
pilar taking off he's heading for third
on his horse and he will reach on the
slide with a triple
jackie bradley jr 253 with two home runs
and he went on from there a little
trickler on the first base line that
will bring in the run
as jbj is tagged out and pilar comes in
to score and that makes it four to
nothing parrot doubles for trey turner
juan soto moved him to third on the
first out of the ball game but the nats
couldn't bring him in
and he'll chop it right side
and over the first baseman goes the
glove bro turner scores easily juan soto
slides into second that's on the board
here's howie who could make this thing
interesting in a hurry
and that's off of moreland
soto around third coming in to score how
you hold it first
anthonette just like that have cut the
deficit in half two on nobody out i mean
hit it sharply first time
line drive right center
howie being sent by chip hale
stopping at second is cabrera
and the gnats are right back where they
need to be with nobody out here in the
third
so that's it darwins and hernandez
another red sox starter cannot get
through three innings the bases are
loaded for the nine hitter victor robles
swing and a miss and he got him and he
leaves them loaded but they do get three
it's a one run game bottom of the fourth
inning boston leading 4-3 kevin pallar
that's a high deep drive left field that
one's socked to the seats and over the
seats a home run by kevin pillar
along with the triple now has a blast to
make it 5-3 that ball was crushed over
everything you heard sanchez yell he
knew as soon as he let it go the ball is
gone top half of inning number five and
austin bryce will inherit a couple of
base runners two on and two out top of
the order and a red hot hitter and trey
turner who's already three for three
and line drive and he's got another hit
that drops into left field here comes
the run suzuki trying to score play at
the plate and he is out at home wow
verdugo has thrown him out verdugo made
a perfect throw
to home plate from left center field to
get him
matt barnes trying to get a win here for
the red sox and that brings up a man who
spent six years with the boston red sox
brockhole and the 02 from his former
teammate
and a swing animus and down he goes
strike three so two away in the night
sends up thames who is one for two two
walks tonight in the 3-2
and a shot into shallow right scooped up
by chavis and that's the ball game
red sox win it they did this one with
the bullpen tonight
final